what's up Wolfgang apparently it's
Thor's birthday and we've learned
something very special due to this we
found out that his old roommate and
teammate during the civil war time has
survived Thanos to snap average everyday
people daryl is an average sort of
everyday guy so it works out well but if
you think it's been easy on him you are
wrong in all seriousness I thought this
was pretty funny I love this kit that
they did before with Daryl and Thor so I
thought you'd all like to see it a
reminder about the giveaway still going
on giving away a few copies of Avengers
infinity war on blu-ray if you would
like to enter for your chance to win all
you have to do is subscribe to my
channel like this video and comment
below with your favorite superhero good
news Daryl survived the snap bad news a
lot of my co-workers didn't so I'm
working Sundays
this video is to say happy birthday Thor
however many thousands of years old you
are I hope you're having a good time out
there in the universe and if there
happens to be Wi-Fi where you are if you
could just do a quick transfer I mean
quite a bit of debt since you left
happy birthday Thor I miss you and I
hope you're having a good day
[Music]
I hope you all enjoyed that thank you so
much for watching
woof woof we're having some relationship
problems dear Steve Rogers do you
remember when i goaded you into killing
those prisoners and you made me swear to
never tell the other Avengers if there's
any other secrets you need kept just let
me know